[Música]
fue el desfile más esperado durante la
semana en la que se presentaron las
colecciones de invierno 2022 2.023 de
moda masculina el de louis vuitton
[Aplausos]
[Música]
acróbatas atletas bailarines un desfile
excepcional para rendirle homenaje a
virgil habló el director creativo de la
marca que murió de un cáncer el 28 de
noviembre de 2021 a los 41 años durante
ocho temporadas contribuyó a darle
visibilidad a los cánones culturales y
artísticos negros y a defender la causa
anti racista a través de un streetwear
de lujo si bien la moda se juzga ante
todo por la calidad de sus productos
también juega con los códigos del
marketing del siglo 21 en particular a
través de las colaboraciones estos tenis
de lujo una de las últimas creaciones de
virgin la blog combinan los famosos
estampados wheaton con el sello de nike
y serán subastados y las ganancias se
destinarán a una organización benéfica
las colaboraciones permiten que las
marcas generen expectativa y deseo entre
los consumidores por adquirir productos
de edición limitada la joven marca
parisina de con lap se alió con la
empresa de calzado estadounidense cross
es una marca que comparte nuestros
valores valores de inclusión diversidad
creatividad y por eso vimos que nuestros
universos se podían conjugar bien así
que desde el principio empezamos a
discutir la idea de crear algo que
pudiera combinar lo digital y lo físico
y lanzamos esta colaboración basada en 5
ene efe test que ya están disponibles
para la subasta el dinero recaudado será
destinado a una organización que
facilita el acceso a lo digital para los
estudiantes y los que más lo necesitan
volvemos a los metaversos esos famosos
universos digitales queríamos crear un
puente con el futuro con la creación del
futuro para todas las personas que ya se
están inclinando solo digital y crecimos
nuestra marca creció en estar digital
así que no queríamos abandonar el
enfoque digital pero aspira vamos a
tener algo muy físico por eso creamos
este metaverso es un lugar en el que las
personas pueden encontrar una especie de
refugio dentro del ámbito digital dentro
del templo lo pueden encontrar en ningún
lado puntocom en francia los metaversos
todavía no despiertan mucho entusiasmo
una encuesta realizada por el instituto
ifop reveló que tan sólo el 8 por ciento
de las personas interrogadas tienen
previsto crear un clon digital y no se
trata de un tema generacional
que apenas tiene 24 años acaba de lanzar
su segunda marca george bend el nombre
de una antigua sastrería poco conocida
en el barrio lo sentía de parís
eso va a cambiar muchas cosas pero a mí
personalmente no me interesa mucho lo
que yo hago es dirigido a personas de
verdad tomé esa decisión y puede ser una
decisión un poco complicada porque tengo
muchos amigos de mi edad que están
viendo a trabajar en esos medios
digitales lo que yo siempre digo es que
quiero trabajar en algo real es muy
importante para mí así que esa también
es la razón por la que cree sorprender
para empezar a vestir a mis propios
amigos y hacer algo real y palpable para
mí siento que estoy muy cerca pero al
mismo tiempo muy lejos de todo lo que he
decidido hacer
este diseñador también prefiere el
contacto con los seres humanos más que
con las máquinas lucania mini presenta
en parís vor y land una colección unisex
que concibió en sudáfrica a su país de
origen en septiembre de 2021 fue uno de
los ganadores del premio karl lagerfeld
en la octava edición de ese prestigioso
galardón hoy celebra el trabajo de los
artesanos de burkina faso
creo que al presentar a mamá verónica
que hace parte de la comunidad tejedora
de burkina faso se muestra el verdadero
origen de la fabricación y también es
posible identificar y ser testigos de la
honestidad y de la integridad entre
tejidas en cada tela eso es en lo que
realmente queríamos profundizar más con
cualquier otra cosa creo que durante
mucho tiempo las personas siempre han
visto los objetos y la ropa pero hay
muchísimas historias detrás de su
fabricación y se trata de redes humanas
y de seres humanos es una comunidad un
colectivo así que tener la oportunidad
de crear un espacio como este y poder
traer a una de las madres para que las
personas realmente puedan ver el
desarrollo del arte y eso es lo que
queremos y es algo en lo que queremos
seguir profundizando
poner de relieve el trabajo artesanal el
trabajo manual en la casa dior homme
queens jones director artístico de la
marca llegó a saludar al público en
compañía del diseñador de sombreros
stephen jones el modista celebra 25 años
de trabajo con la casa dior que este año
también festeja su aniversario número 75
[Música]
y aquí es para mí una inspiración en
vida por su procedencia por lo que hace
por dior y por el ser humano que es
incluso aunque aquí no hubiese nada de
lo que hemos venido a ver
como ser humano él abrió el camino a
muchas personas
estoy muy contenta y me siento muy
privilegiado de estar aquí para apoyarlo
el decorado es realmente mágico todos
los decorados que kim jong ha hecho
desde sus primeros desfiles nos llevan
siempre auto punto gusta a todos desde
sus tenis hasta su confección desde sus
telas hasta sus colores he sido un gran
admirador de king desde el principio
fue divino divino realmente hermoso
espectacularmente chic elegante lo
quiero todo no lo olvide no lo queremos
todo
y la escenografía de fondo lo
reconocieron es el icónico puente
alexander tercero de parís nada más que
eso no se necesita ningún otro ornamento